what is a null set
it's a set like this with no elements
inside it
like the set of sensory organs of your
book
your book is a non-living thing and does
not have ears or eyes
which means it's an empty set or a null
set
they both mean the same
and if you're asked about the set of
sensory organs of a human being we would
have included ears eyes nose etc
anyway the null set is represented using
this symbol
a circle and a line which cuts across
consider the set a with the first three
natural numbers inside it
now think about it is the null set a
subset of the set a
yes the null set is a subset of every
set
but why do we say this
there's actually a funny way to
understand this
you can look at it this way
what does the null set contain nothing
what does set a contain
it contains 1 2 3 and nothing
this means that nothing is a part of set
a2
and that's why we say that the null set
is a subset of set a
because every set has nothing apart from
the other elements the null set is a
subset of every set
and yes the null set is also a subset of
the null set
since both sets have nothing
and this is also obvious as we know that
every set is a subset of itself
you